(traffic passing by)
- [Man] The hardest part
was just kind of feeling
like I was a failure.
(building music)
Why am I sleeping here
with my kids in my car?
(soft music)
- We've seen a great shift
in the last few years
as we came out of the recession
where it's not the job issue anymore
it's the housing prices.
People who have born,
raised, generations here
that are finding themselves homeless.
And it's just families getting pushed out.
And it has nothing to
do with income, jobs.
It's just the doubling of rent.
- Well my wife works for a dental.
My brother's a general manager for Shell.
Even with that, we still find it hard
to even get a place to live.
'Cause we got jobs, so
since we got income,
we can't qualify for programs
that consider us homeless.
Two bedroom apartments
that are like almost $1900.
Is that something that we can afford?
No.
- Without any changes,
we don't see this problem
getting any better in the near future.
- [Darrick] Eva, come on.
Come on, look at me.
Ay, bye-bye.
- Bye bye.
- [Darrick] We had an apartment.
We were doing good.
- [Lola] We had become good
friends with our landlord,
and they were selling to a realty company.
They were basically just
interested in freezing us out.
We decided it was time to leave.
- The places that we were finding
wanted like three times the rent
or they wanted 650 credit score or above.
We didn't have that going on.
- The motels were first.
We went to the motels and
tore through our savings.
So then we went to the emergency shelter,
and it was just a tailspin at that point.
What we did discover
is that being in a car
was far better for us as a family
than being slopped in with people,
kind of pressed against us.
- So my thoughts I was like oh my gosh,
I'm gonna sleep in my car,
and it's gonna be all of these weirdos,
but then I got there and it's just,
they're just people, they're just going
through the same thing I was.
All right, love you guys.
See you later.
- [Lola] Darrick has
almost always had job.
- When I started working at
the drug treatment facility,
I'd get up at five, get ready,
and then I'd leave the lot
and I wouldn't get back
'til like three o'clock.
I was always tired.
There was people depending on me.
I can't just sit and wallow and be sad.
I have things I have to take care of,
and I want my family to be happy
and I want to be happy.
We were in and out of the car
for I think about four years.
It wasn't the best
experience at all times,
but there were some great memories.
- [Lola] We would drive to a nearby park
and I got to watch the sun rise.
Say good morning to the whole city.
It felt hopeful in those moments.
- Hi!
I'm Mimi.
- And I'm Lola.
- So we're here at the library.
Well, every single day
was kind of different.
- [Daughter] Home is where you live.
Home is where you
will be passion-able.
- [Daughter] Home, I don't know, cars.
- Well I've been here almost five years
and I just like to see when people come
into this place they get
a place to call their own,
and I have a little happy
dance that I do for them.
I say,
♪ I'm so proud of you ♪
And that's it, and then
I jump up and down.
(laughing)
- We moved out of the car
and I really like this
place, so it's kind of cool.
- 14, 15,
16.
Ready or not, here I come.
Found you.
(laughing)
I think we're still kind
of getting used to it.
(laughing)
Every once in a while I
wake up I go oh, whoa,
whoa there's not a roof right here.
What's going on?
We got lucky.
(yelling)
You're fine!
You're fine.
- Yay.
♪ I believe I can fly ♪
- Yeah we've had ups and downs,
we just need to get through it.
Band together.
(yelling)
(soft music)
Can you hold it?
My dad used to do this.
He'd go, you'll know when it's ready,
when it sticks to the wall.
- [Mom] So what was your
favorite part of today?
- My favorite part is when me and Mommy
went to do laundry.
- Well I liked doing lessons with you,
I thought you did good today.
What about you?
- I think this is the highlight of my day.
We all hang out and have dinner together.
- Yeah.
- People should understand
about the situation
is it could happen to anyone.
- Hi, guys.
- At the last second, I veered.
How you doing?
Good.
Nice to see you.
- Things are going good?
- Yeah, they're going good.
We miss you.
We miss saying hi to you.
- Okay.
- And having a sense of community.
- And, go.
- It's kind of bittersweet in a way.
But at the same time it's a relief, too.
When we first left, in our
apartment it was too quiet.
We were all like.
- Yeah.
- I don't hear no traffic.
- Yeah, we didn't hear any.
It sounds like the ocean to me.
For the most part it was
a positive experience.
Because we just chose for them to be.
Yeah?
- When are we gonna leave?
I don't wanna be here so long.
- [Woman] Would you like your phone?
- No.
- [Woman] You wanna go
sit in the car with dada?
- No.
- Hey, are you afraid that
we're gonna be staying here?
- Yeah.
- We're not staying here, honey.
We're going back to our apartment.
(soft music)
♪ Somewhere over the rainbow ♪
♪ Way up high ♪
♪ There's a land that I
heard of once in a lullaby ♪
♪ Some day I wish upon a star ♪
♪ Wake up where the
clouds are far behind me ♪